if you've been following my channel for
a while you'll know Apple TV plus has
been popping off with some excellent
mystery shows from Severance to Silo and
today we have a new Contender the
changeling and in this video we'll be
looking at the biggest mysteries for
episodes one to three I have not read
the book this show is based off so there
will be no book spoilers but for those
of you who have feel free to laugh along
at all my incorrect theories as always
I've left timestamps below to all the
topics I'll be covering now let's get
into it the events of the changeling
seem somehow tied to Norway the very
first scene of episode 1 tells of a
Norwegian ship making the impossible
Crossing to America in 1825. on board
are 52 men seeking freedom from
religious persecution I can't help but
think that one of these men may be
related to either Apollo or Emma the
narrator who's voiced by the actual
book's author Victor Laval states that
the only way the ship survived was with
help and if you look real close you can
almost see what looks to be a
supernatural entity guiding the ship
through these Troubled Waters this same
Supernatural entity can also be seen
approaching Manhattan at the end of
episode 2. there's also the mention of a
Norwegian photographer that Emma had a
fling with while traveling to South
America Michelle Emma's friend mentions
to Apollo that this photographer has a
nude photograph of her and it was sold
to a gallery owner who continues to
display it to this day I wouldn't be
surprised if Apollo goes searching for
this photographer and if he happens to
live in New York after all Manhattan is
a mecca for art galleries we also have
father Hagin Hagen being a surname of
Norwegian and Dutch origin Emma wants to
get her child Brian baptized by him and
Apollo will attend these support groups
where Hagen is in attendance I'm not
exactly sure what the Norway connection
is as of yet but there are far too many
connections for this to be a coincidence
in episode 1 we learned that Apollo is
named after Apollo read from the movie
Rocky in Roman and Greek mythology
Apollo is a god something Apollo himself
often refers to himself as I am the god
Apollo with the show leaning heavily
into fairy tales and mythology this is a
conscious choice on the part of the
writers since Apollo's father is no
longer in the picture Apollo took the
last name kagwa his mother's maiden name
Lillian Apollo's mother came to America
from Uganda and there just so happens to
be a famous Apollo kagwa from you
guessed it Uganda he was an influential
political leader and intellectual I
should also note that in Greek mythology
Apollo had a twin brother named Artemis
knowing how many Secrets his mother had
and the Mystery surrounding his father I
wouldn't be surprised if there's a twin
brother who may or may not have been
raised by the father another myth comes
from the name of this restaurant
umibozu in Japanese folklore that Umi
bozu is a sea Spirit who turns the
waters tumultuous and attacks ships I
can't help but think of that
Supernatural entity that was seen by the
Norwegians could a deal have been made
with this creature and the sailors to
ensure their survival one which curses
the their descendants to this day one
thing I found really odd was the sheer
amount of missing children posters that
appear in New York not just in present
day but also in the past we see multiple
posters on lamp posts and even on milk
cartons something or someone is taking
these children and if you ask me this
has something to do with the wise ones
which I'll get more into near the end of
the video throughout his whole life
Apollo was told that his father
abandoned him but in the third episode
it's revealed that it was his mother who
pushed him away and wanted a divorce in
fact his father would come in secret and
visit him as a child every Saturday
while Lillian had to work until she
found out about it and put it into that
it wasn't until Apollo's 12th birthday
that he'd leave a box marked in probably
a Latin word meaning improbable
improbably is also the name of Apollo's
book selling business which can be seen
on his business card and honestly his
job is very improbable imagine finding a
postcard written by the infamous is a
cultist Alistair Crowley then a few
months later a signed copy of To Kill a
Mockingbird with a personal message to
Truman Capote this is truly improbable
but let's examine the contents of this
box and see if there are any clues first
we have a photo of Lillian kind of looks
like a modeling picture perhaps taken
while she was working at the modeling
agency and this piece of paper is really
hard to make out but it could be a
marriage certificate up next is a
receipt for one night at the elk hotel
in times squared signed by Lillian why
on Earth would Apollo's father keep this
receipt was it the night Apollo was
conceived does it prove some sort of
infidelity we just don't know then
there's this creepy fictitious
children's book called to the waters in
the wild which is a line repeated in a
Yates poem called The Stolen Child I'm
no poem analyst but check out these
lines Here Come Away o human child to
the waters and the wild with a fairy
hand in hand for the world's more full
of weeping than you can understand it's
almost as if these fairies are taking
children away to protect them from the
harms of the world and what we have here
on the first page quote a baby is a
dream made real but dreams are the
fairy's favorite meal these
quote-unquote fairies want these
children and guess who happens to be
missing a ton of children now this idea
of Dreams comes up a lot throughout the
show check out the sign behind Apollo as
he waits for Emma's return from Brazil
follow your dream the inscription by
Harper Lee to Truman Capote reads dear
pip here's to the daddy of our dreams
Apollo experiences several dreams
including his faceless father coming to
get him I also want to bring up this
scene where Apollo says goodbye to Emma
at the airport is it just me or does it
look like she completely vanishes after
an extra walks past the screen here we
see her talking to the gate chicken lady
this guy walks past and boom she's gone
now look at Apollo's reaction it's
almost like where did she go it was at
this point that I need to take
everything we see from Apollo's
perspective with a grain of salt he may
not be a reliable narrator am I going
too far here let me know what you think
about this in the comments below and
while you're at it if you're enjoying
this video and want to see me cover the
rest of the season be sure to like And
subscribe while visiting South America
Emma found a lagoon the locals warned
her not to visit there we find an
elderly woman credited simply as the old
Washerwoman but she definitely gives off
witch Vibes her look is also very
interesting encompassing both white and
black features one eye is blue and the
other black her hair is blonde but her
skin is black the show deals a lot with
interracial marriage and what it means
to be biracial and I couldn't help but
think that this was a conscious decision
without having met Emma this woman
somehow knows her name and decides to
Grant her three wishes these wishes will
come true when the red strand tied
around her wrist breaks maybe
coincidence Dental but the bookstore
Apollo visits in episode 2 is called
Strand and its color is red it's also
Apollo who ends up cutting the Strand
and these wishes seemingly come true we
know from Emma's friend that two of
these wishes do come true one to find a
good husband and two to have a healthy
child but we never find out what this
third wish is all we know is that it has
something to do with the look she gave
into the camera while posing for her
nude photo a look which Michelle said is
both frightening and that of a sorceress
the narrator states to be careful what
we wish for so it seems these wishes
come at a price and Emma certainly pays
for it later killing her child at the
end of episode 3 Apollo learns that this
woman at his support group was seeking
help by a group called the mothers also
known as the wise ones these women
promised her that she could get her
child back like Emma she had been
receiving creepy photos of someone
stalking her photos that would somehow
disappear the term wise ones comes from
the Richard buck book Wicca for life and
it's all about witches the photo we see
on the cell phone of which is burning at
the stake can also be found in the
show's title credits members of this
group seem to communicate on some sort
of message board and its leader is Cal
when Emma goes to collect the chains
she'll use to tie up Apollo she says it
was Cal who sent her now when I think of
the name Cal I usually think of a man
however since Cal is heavily connected
with the mothers perhaps even its leader
I'm inclined to believe this is a woman
and Cal may even be short for Calliope
now this gets even more interesting
because in Greek mythology Calliope is
get this the mother of Apollo does this
mean Lillian is this leader it could be
she never really liked Emma telling her
that her breasts were quote wrong and
didn't like how Emma was Raising Brian
out of the Christian faith we also know
that Lillian has been keeping secrets so
I think there's a whole lot more
backstory here that we haven't dug into
the creepy photos are another odd
mystery found in the changeling at first
I thought these were all in Emma's head
but when it's revealed that another
woman got them and she was able to print
one off before it got deleted and kind
of put that theory to rest it's clear
whoever is taking these photos wants
those children and as of now the only
real entity that we know who wants these
kids are fairies if the show has witches
in it then why not fairies too could we
being some sort of conflict between
witches and fairies and are the witches
bad or could they actually be good as
Emma delves further into her Mania she
becomes increasingly distant from her
husband and child eventually calling her
son not hers and the devil there's even
this homeless guy who yells at her
saying quote it's not a baby it's those
same words Emma will utter to Apollo
before cracking his skull with a hammer
overall it's hard to tell what's real or
not in this show almost all our
characters suffer from some sort of
mental illness and their perspectives
can't be taken at face value value with
that being said I'm really curious where
this show is headed and I'll be with you
every step of the way this season now I
want to hear from you what did you think
of the first three episodes of the
changeling I want to hear your thoughts
and theories in the comments below
thanks for watching be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
to stay
foreign